we are going to be doing another
live podcast at the will turn theater
did we ever tell you about this i don't
think you did yeah well we are you are
and you're going to be there oh cool
okay
you're going to realize while you're on
stage
that you're doing a podcast
that's how adult you are now that you
have twins yes huh what oh yes well
hello audience yeah uh yeah may 4th
wilton theater we are going to be doing
another live podcast the first one we
did was such a blast we've got a great
uh surprise guest
very very excited about this show it is
sold out oh but
you can follow at team coco for free
tickets that's cool yeah so come and see
us and it's all being made possible by
the good people at chevrolet i was
wondering why this chevrolet logo was
behind you you know what initially yeah
i just put up the chevrolet logo because
i think it's a nice logo okay and i
didn't even know that chevrolet was
involved
i've always thought as auto logos go
chevy has the best one oh that's nice i
just think it's beautiful it's
absolutely gorgeous cool yeah and i i've
always had um the chevy logo in
my bedroom my living room okay i'm just
a fan i'm just a fan
and uh you know i have to say i am a fan
of chevrolet because
first car
when i my first memories are my dad
driving me around in our 1963
chevy impala oh that's cool yeah it was
blue and the steering wheel squeaked
they don't squeak anymore chevy took
care of that issue but um i remember
that really well i remember my dad
driving me and me sitting there was a
bench seat uh really cool we had that
car forever and so yeah and uh i'm
excited uh chevy has been a trusted name
in transportation
for 100 years no
yes okay and cars have only been around
like 70 years i think for the first 30
yeah chevy was building chairs and stuff
and putting wheels on them
um
yeah yeah and they said this trust me
it's going to be a car eventually
um you mr chevy yeah thank you mr chevy
they've always been there for you
uh and for the people and you know i'm
also excited because as you know i'm a
big fan of electric vehicles yes evs and
um
chevy
is coming out with an incredible line of
electric vehicles and that makes me
happy i mean vehicles for
whatever your budget is they have a
vehicle for you whatever your needs are
whatever stage you are in life
they have a vehicle for you are they
gonna have an electric truck well here's
one i want to talk about they are
they're i'm glad you asked me that my
favorite truck name of all time yeah
you can't beat it silverado
you have to say it like that you do
silver
that's like the best and you know when i
i'm sure they have pitch meetings where
they sit around and they think what
truck name hasn't been used
the other car companies must just want
to they just must be going crazy that
they missed out on silverado it's a good
one yeah cause when you say like i'm
headed over to your place really what
are you coming in
silverado
that's the coolest
right it's even cooler now that it's
going to be electric yeah it's going to
be i think that's coming out next year
i'm i i just think that's an amazing
name yeah
i'm excited
uh our thanks to chevrolet for making
this possible may 4th wilton theater and
as i said it's sold out but uh follow at
team coco for free tickets